le dossier patrick dils reste marquée
par le doute la journée d'audience était
très attendue avec le témoignage de
francis heaulme une nouvelle fois le
tueur en série affirmé qu'il n'était pas
le meurtrier des deux enfants une
audience suivi par stéphanie perez et
jérémie drieu la déposition de francis
heaulme était extrêmement attendu at
elle tant que la petite salle de la cour
d'assises de lui on a pu accueillir tous
les passionnés de la faire
houlme les épaules voûtées parle avec
difficulté
il regarde patrick dils je pense souvent
à lui dit il
mais comme à reims il répète je n'ai pas
tué les deux enfants
je suis un tueur en série mais j'en ai
marre qu'on me met tout sur le dos je
suis un bouclier émissaire baffo itil
quant à ses déclarations sur l'homme en
ce sens qu'il a vu il affirme avoir dit
n'importe quoi parce que le capitaine
ans présents dans la salle ne le
respectez pas
il a été égal à lui-même c'est-à-dire
qu'il acquit n'importe quoi une chose et
son contraire
deux secondes d'intervalle
et
je crois ça permet peut-être de mesurer
sa sincérité finalement pas ce qu'ils
disent des choses qui ne sont pas en sa
faveur il dit chaque fois qu'on
m'interroge c'est une nouvelle version
le procès piétine mais la défense de
patrick dils restent persuadées de
l'implication de om le trou par exemple
très intéressant qu'à la fin il disait
madame b écrit je mahler émouvante je
vous jure sur la tombe de ma mère que je
n'ai pas tué pour deux enfants
l'ennui c'est qu'il dit aux gendarmes 3
il ya trois semaines je vous jure que
c'est henri leclerc qui a tué les deux
enfants que je l' ai vu le doute
persiste la confusion est telle que la
présidente du tribunal appelle même par
erreur l'accusé dit patrick il ne nous
apporte pas d'élément déterminant qui
pourraient l'incriminé dans cette
histoire avait dans cette affaire on
reste toujours sur la même situation
avec un dossier particulièrement
accablante les concerne pas tout on n'a
pas de réponse
francis heaulme affirme avoir dit
n'importe quoi sous la pression des
enquêteurs
les défenseurs de patrick dils savent
maintenant que s'ils veulent obtenir
l'acquittement du jeune homme
ils doivent prouver que lui aussi a pu
dire n'importe quoi sous cette même
pression